ce soir nos mémoires du zinc sont
consacrés à jacques higelin jacques
higelin qui avait semble-t-il disparu
depuis huit ans enfin c'est ce que
certains pensaient mais vous verrez
c'est pas du tout le cas et il revient
avec un nouvel album je crois avec le
15e c'est amor doloroso alors avant de
leur ressort sortie le 20 novembre
petite ardoise chez emi et vous êtes en
tournée à partir de janvier et au
bataclan du 6 au 10 mars
est ce que tout ça est bon ça ira ça ira
bon jacques higelin
bonsoir ou bonjour ça va alors je repose
ma petite ardoise
alors j'ai commencé en disant je vous
aviez disparu c'est faux vous étiez dans
une longue tournée
alors qu'est ce qui vous a fait revenir
à l'écriture mais j'ai jamais cessé
vraiment gt gt pas absents j'étais
ailleurs j'étais sur des scènes un peu
partout en france et dans le monde
d'ailleurs j'ai pas je faisais plein de
choses quand je vivais oui je continue à
vivre d'ailleurs je parle au passé comme
s'il était mon pas du tout je vive je
vis et et donc des fois on n'apparaît
pas mais on continue je sais pas on
s'éclate on vit on rencontre des gens on
fait de la musique on chante gens et
j'ai envie de ça va ce qui joue l'un ce
10 mai mais j'ai pas expliquer ce que je
fais mais il faut que jacques higelin
comprennent que les gens l'aiment aient
envie de savoir je lui dirais que non
mais j'ai dit à jacques higelin que
cette curiosité la à une curiosité
d'amour voilà c'est ça c'est ça que je
voulais mais je vous dirai ça lui fera
plaisir voilà ben je l'espère on va donc
comme essayer d'en savoir plus sur
chaque qui joue l'un à travers donc
cesser ben oui bon ça va j'ai
l'impression que jackie chan à un
dialogue avec jacques higelin compressé
de gpa schizophrène alors figure libre
la figure libre est incarnée par cette
petite voilà cette petite way danseuses
sur son sur son petit miroir et 700 g
si chez walt disney ce nom c'est une
allée à lui surtout mignonnette
trouvaient dans un sas a fait un peu de
traits walt disney vert alors notre
petite danseuse de disneyland va vous
donner l'occasion de traiter un sujet
dans l'actualité dernièrement qui vous a
soit irrité soit sur lequel vous avez
envie de parler quels sujets vous avez
choisi quand j'étais revenu de l'album
c'était cash en cachant j'étais passé et
vois pas ce que j'ai trouvé incroyable
si on traite aussi légèrement la vie de
familles d'enfants de gens qu'on avait
délogé et j'ai trouvé ça pas
particulièrement révélateur de la
politique qu'on nous prépare ses portes
et on parle d'un truc qui m'a vraiment
choquée où je me suis dit tiens
humainement
est-ce qu'on serait tombé dans un ça
vous a surpris loïs mme que on s'en fout
quand des enfants sous prétexte pas
peut-être qu'ils sont parce qu'ils sont
africains d'origine d'en face et des
français et ça ça me choque d'autant
plus que je voudrais bien qu'on accepte
enfin un moment donné de reconnaître
comme français les gens qui habitent qui
travaillent qui est qui saïd qui
apprennent la langue qui à un moment
donné son font partie de notre pays
alors que la terre en tout cas tant que
la paf fini par virer les frontières et
laisser les gens chez eux c'est-à-dire
sur terre vous disais quand même dans
votre commentaire me faisait par rapport
à une politique qu'on nous prépare quand
on vit où nous prépare c'est à dire
qu'on va arrêter on va envoyer dans des
sacs qu'on propose des airs et justement
moi c'est des bases comme ça qui me
motive c'est à dire en partant des gens
les plus en difficulté
est-ce qu'on bâtit la politique à partir
de ça ou est-ce que
on bâtit la politique à partir d'une
idée de prod2
de gain économique c'est-à-dire le
pognon comme kim est plein de gens sur
le carreau
bon c'est tout ouais après les candidats
à haut pouvoir à l'élection
présidentielle instant j'ai du mal à
discerner quelqu'un qu'il a la carrure
pour arbitrer ce que je pense qu'un
président santos à quelqu'un qui essaye
de pas d'allumer des conflits mais de
les résoudre
et puis de aussi de partir des plus
démunis pour essayer de les aider les
gens par des lois adéquates pour qu'ils
puissent vivre se loger se nourrir
décemment
je crois que ma mastic danseuses de de
chez disneyland à l'air contente elle
considère que hélas sa réponse merci en
tout cas j'ai kiffé journal
une pompe c'est une une séquence qui est
matérialisée par cette petite balle de
ping pong qu'on donne à notre invité ça
me déstresse dans cette balle de
ping-pong
elle est là pour essayer de vous faire
vous souvenir et vous exprimer sur un
article où quelque chose qu'on aurait
dit de vous qui vous a ouverte et choqué
vous avez trouvé injuste et sur lequel
vous aimeriez revenir vous un souvenir
d'un truc qui m'a fait marrer surtout
j'avais joué festival en italie à venise
et puis je vois je mets un article le
lendemain dans un journal italien
et comme je comprenais pas j'ai demandé
à d'ailleurs une fiche camp qui était
assez belle qui était gracieuse et qui
me dit je parle français
quant à lui traduire leur l'article et
elle m'a des chiffres est tranquillement
tout l'article qui me démolissait l'aigu
face aux restos charbon en restant là
ils disent attendre j'arrive pas à lire
bien et disent oui ce type très minable
qui croient qu'il est bon alors qu'il
est quel est le mot exact alors qu'il
est ridicule ridicule ce sens qu'ils
disent et elle traduisait avec une une
énorme bonne foi pas du tout de
méchanceté rustique qui me battait qui
me dégommait grave et j'ai trouvé ça
extrêmement marrant quoi génial avec l
mignonne et gentil vous le rendre
service et puis à la fin ils ont dit
qu'ils retournent chez lui on n'a pas
besoin de chanteurs aussi france est
aussi nul et elle m'a regardé dit voilà
je pense que c'est je traduis à peu près
qu est ce qu ils disent que j'ai dit non
merci
il n'y a pas de quoi ça m'a fait plaisir
comme ça j'ai trouvé ça très bien toute
façon j'ai eu déjà des trucs
des phrases c'est peut-être mérité aussi
des fois on n'est pas bon voilà c'est
tout j'ai side ça aide des critiques qui
aident toutes façons on lit jamais que
les questions qu'on se pose soi même
quand on cherche un truc pareil merci à
cette charmante traductrice italienne de
vous avoir avoir évoqué ce souvenir à
passion d'auteur donc la passion
d'auteur alors on utilise un miroir de
qui avait avez vous envie de parler et
romain garric j'aime beaucoup
y'a tient tout simplement des fois des
livres qu'on lit il ya un livre que j'ai
lu il ya quelques temps extraordinaires
d'un homme qui s'appelle stéphane
audeguy que ses fils unique
ou alors c'est la théorie des nuages la
théorie de la nature et des nuages
j'ai trouvé ça magnifique l'écriture
magnifique tout ce qu'il raconte je veux
dire à tout le monde parce que ce disque
ce livre je le défend vraiment pour les
gens vis de le faire connaître
parce que c'est un livre merveilleux on
peut lui prédire un grand grand grand
grand avenir
c'est un grand écrivain alors romain
gary c'est intéressant parce qu'il ya
quand même des cibles que vous aimez
romain garric est très très très
différent de de stéphane audeguy il
m'apporte beaucoup sur la connaissance
de l'homme sur l'humanité avec ses
travers avec ses les clowneries
et puis des tas de bouquins promesse de
l'aube et comme marguerite duras que
j'aime profondément aussi et puis le
dernier disque de brigitte fontaine
ça s'appelle nouvelles de l'exil celle
des nouvelles et c'est absolument
magnifique
en tout cas on retient l'album on
recevra avec les plaisirs sucrés avec
plaisir ici pour ce nouvel album on
dirait ivoire merci pour cette passion
de l'auteur journal intime alors le
journal intime petite caméra
cette caméra que je vous remets vous
êtes en charge avec elle de nous emmener
dans un endroit où dans un moment
est ce que vous pourriez - moi je me
j'ai un souvenir
vous avez participé à une sorte de radio
crochet en fait de concours de chant et
grâce à ce concours vous avez gagné un
voyage à nice ouais c'était la première
fois vous veillez l'achat quartier avec
ma mère parce que ça n'est que jaillit
avec une adulte
j'étais adolescent enfants et là j'ai
découvert ma grand mère maternelle où ma
mère n'avait plus revu sa mère depuis
des années des années 20
je me revois on a retrouvé l'adresse par
quelqu'un je peux pas avant de partir
puisque on avait su que j'avais gagné le
concours et je suis monté au quatrième
étage
je vais y remédier et coûteux j'ai pas
envie d'y aller elle avait peur ma mère
elle se dit mais moi je vais y aller je
suis son petit fils après tout je suis
monté j'ai frappé à la porte et une
femme âgée qui m'a ouvert
il médite qui est une anti garçon qu'est
ce que tu veux si je suis votre petit
fils elle m'a dit ça l'a tellement
secoué pas dit mais elle avait l'accent
belge en plus d'y ouvrir et ta mère dit
elle en bas mehdi lui de monter elle
était secret quoi c'était beau parce que
finalement grâce à ce concours elle se
sont revus et se sont réconciliés et
pluess mais très famille est-ce que vous
avez des relations avec vos parents ou
grands-parents femme je ne sais pas si
ça minier
j'ai des relations avec mes enfants bien
sûr vous avez un fils comédiens infi
chanteur et une fille chanteuse ouais et
c'est marrant parce qu'en arrivant
j'écoute la radio et j'entends arthur
qui chantait comment ça s'appelle adieu
tristesse et je me régalais jamais je
l'adorent et un coup j'ai réalisé que je
laime en tant qu'artiste hocine et ben
en fait très honnêtement et avec du
recul
j'aime mais enfin j'aime ce qu'ils font
aussi alors j'ai de la chance parce que
admettons que je les aime et puis
j'aimerais pas ce qu'ils font ce serait
ça changerait rien je les voyais quand
même mais j'ai de la chance comme plus
je suis fier d'eux ps qui se réunissent
les jeunes à inscrire dès noël se tient
sur noël on devrait le faire
bonne idée ça je crois que à partir de
ce journal intime dont prenait
l'engagement la regarder face à la
caméra
voilà et à former ou est-ce que vos
enfants que à noël on se voit ouais je
vous donne rendez vous soyez sympa mais
avant le papa il soit trop vieux
grand-père avant qu'il puisse plus voir
non mais c'est pas de leur fauteuil
demande pas mieux bon c'est moi des fois
je suis pris et tout bon en tout cas la
carte postale a été envoyée je voudrais
rappeler l'album à mort de l'ohio nord
ça se prononce de l'os tournée à partir
de janvier et au bataclan du 6 au 10
mars à paris
attaquants jacques higelin en tout cas
merci moi ça m'a fait très plaisir
je ne voyais pas à noël les jeunes en
famille oui si c'est possible ça serait
bien bas merci jacques higelin merci
[Musique]